civilian evacuations are underway in
ukraine's donetsk region with russia
stepping up its attacks since claiming
full control of neighboring luhansk the
city of slovansk has become a main
target for shelling but towns across
ukraine's east are being bombarded
missiles struck kharhiv on wednesday
destroying a university ukrainian forces
have dug in with new defensive lines and
president voladimir zelensky said
western supplied weapons were finally
making a difference on the battlefield
well for more i'm joined by dw
correspondent nick spicer who's standing
by for us in kiev good to see you nick
now the russian offensive in the donbass
is grinding on what is the latest news
you can bring us
well we've had a tactical retreat that
you were just explaining earlier where
the ukrainian troops who had been
defending uh
for weeks whereas we thought it would be
a matter of days we kept hearing it's
going to fall tomorrow and they held out
for a long time uh evacuated preventing
another sort of mario paul situation
where the soldiers are taken prisoner
and you know brought to russia and so on
and they're now taking up those
defensive positions you were referring
to
in the donetsk region which is the
region that vladimir putin needs to take
in order to control the entire donbass
which he says is the next objective he
said that earlier uh this week however
they're dug in really deeply and they've
also managed to evade being caught in
the cauldron that the germans pardon me
the russians were talking about catching
them within so taking up positions in
slovenians because you were saying
preparing to defend that city but also
cram a taurus which is a critical uh
transport and rail hub so awaiting the
sort of onslaught which will come as per
usual via massive artillery barrages and
then at some point if the russians are
so inclined at street by street fighting
when they feel comfortable and safe
enough to do that
now nick president zelinski's address
overnight said that uh heavy weapons
from
western allies have finally begun
working at full capacity did he give any
indication of how this would actually
help in the war
yeah i would say there those that are
there are working at full capacity but
it's very uh we're very far from being
at the full uh you know wish list what
ukrainians want one example there are
four american highmars systems which are
these precise
precision guided missile systems
ukrainians want 300 of them what they
can do however is fire rockets uh into
russian uh occupied territory within one
meter accuracy the ukrainian rockets and
russian rockets up till now have 500
meters accuracy so you can pinpoint
something very precisely and what
zylenski said in his speech was that
they were going after no surprise here
depots of ammunition because the uh or
ukrainians are massively outgoing 15 10
to one when it comes to artillery shells
going one way or the other so the
logical thing is just to take out those
stalks of ammunition and that's what the
ukrainians say they're doing as well as
command and control centers sort of cut
the head off the snake and make it
harder for the russians to control their
troops and that's been a consistent
problem for them throughout this
campaign
nick spicer in kiev thank you
well with ukraine's eastern province of
luhansk now under russian control moscow
has been stepping up its offensive in
neighboring donetsk together they make
up the donbass which russia wants to
seize completely so let's take a look at
this map now this is the territory that
russia has now taken in ukraine it
includes the city as you can see there
of
chansk
which was the last bastion of ukrainian
resistance in the luhansk region now
analysts say the battle for slavyansk
down here is the next key contest in the
struggle for the donbass and experts
also believe that russian forces are
attempting to advance west from lisi
chance to the town of siversk and they
suggest that russia is likely to try to
push towards bachmut
from the south
well let's bring in a military analyst
um and also former british army officer
mike martin uh good to see you and
thanks for joining us here on dw um so
president zielanski says the heavy
weapons from ukraine's western allies
are working at full capacity how much of
a concern is this though for the russian
forces
i i think it does make a difference
particularly the longer-range artillery
that your correspondent cited in the
earlier reports
what that allows the ukrainians to do
is to do what's called counter-battery
fire so targeting
russian artillery and that means that
the russian artillery uh has to move and
the more it has to move between firing
the less effective it is
as well your correspondence cited that
with the longer range and some of the
high mars can go up to
450 kilometers so that's obviously a
very long way
they can use that to target a supply
deposit ammunition depots and we've seen
a number of russian depots uh being
blown up or targeted by artillery over
the last week two weeks
now mike russian president vladimir
putin has declared victory for russian
forces in luhansk and the focus um has
shifted to slavyansk and that's
according to british intelligence
is it a matter of time before the entire
donbass falls to russia or
is that looking a little bit less likely
now considering this uh information that
we've just been talking about
i think it's an open question as to
whether the russians will be able to
control the whole of the donbass your
viewers will probably have seen recently
that yesterday president putin announced
an operational pause
and
this is basically a cessation of
military activities so that they can
regroup and whilst it is normal
you wouldn't do it unless you had to
which tells us that the russians have
experienced either lots of casualties
lots of battle damage to their equipment
or they are running low on supplies
so
i think it is possible that the russians
will take uh the whole of the donbass
but in in a sense if you zoom out to the
strategic picture the question is how
much does that really matter because the
ukrainians are also pushing forward in
the north and in the south
now mike
is it possible that the kremlin is
preparing for a protracted war with the
intention of taking much larger portions
of ukraine
that is possible um but they are going
to need to do a couple of things in
order to do that
the first is to put their economy on a
on a war footing much like uh you know
the countries of europe did in the
second world war for example and we have
seen some slow moves towards that
obviously with the sanctions they've
been having problems getting specific
components so they have been looking at
how they can get around that
but more than that they would need to do
a mobilization of personnel if we look
at
russian losses
okay estimates are very hard to verify
precisely but they're either up to 35
000 or more likely to be about 20 000
russian losses
um replacing those is going to be very
very difficult without announcing a
general mobilization of the russian
population which of course president
putin doesn't want to do because this is
not a war it's only a special military
operation so it will be difficult for
them to do that
military analyst mike martin thank you
thank you
well ukraine's odessa was once one of
the liveliest cities on the black sea
but its port is closed unable to ship
wheat to the world and anyone planning
to go for a swim should think again dw
correspondent emmanuel chas visited the
city and her report was filmed under
conditions set out by the ukrainian
military
we're here in the port city of odessa
southern ukraine usually at this time of
the year the city will be full with
tourists they would sun baths on the
beach except this year a lot of beaches
are mined
the ukrainian armed forces planted mines
on the beaches to stop the russians
landing
of course we do not name or show which
sections of the coast are mined we have
geographical features that are favorable
for landing of troops so if that happens
we have prepared a few
surprises let's say
we're not allowed to fail more than this
our ukrainian military minders say
anything identifiable might help the
russians
locals still come to the beach
they're stressed by air raid alarms and
the absence of tourists
every year come to us many many
million people
and they say it's a beautiful city near
the sea near the black sea
but now
we don't have this
it's uncomfortable
it was nice when we could go to the sea
where would i go
we were born and raised here and
deceased everything for us but in a
current situation we have to be prepared
to make sacrifices for victory for our
future we can breathe any fresh air but
sadly we can't get to the sea anymore
and in the town locals might stroll the
streets
but shops and restaurants are empty
[Music]
germany france and even from the usa
people who worked here especially the
women left the country in the first week
of the war
we kept the restaurants open to provide
food for those who needed it
when or if odessans come home they will
find a city in need of revival